oh man because I don't have a future  and you might hate me for doing this and  you're entitled to hate me  I wish you were direct all that anger  and hatred at our government  they have betraying young people like me  I wouldn't know either if they did their  normal duty to their own citizens  I'm part of the just the oil Coalition  demanding an end to all new oil and gas  licenses in the UK what we're asking for  is what all the scientists are asking  for what the United Nations are asking  for the International Energy the ipcc  how many more people have to say we  don't have a livable future if you  continue licensing oil and gas for you  to listen  people like me I want to put a country  on the M25 for you to listen